[Musique]
ces dispositions a été créée en 1992
quand même pas avec une diversification
en maraîchage et la création d'un
bâtiment d'élevage en fuite possible le
bâtiment d'élevage été créée au départ
1992 avec un quota de 27,8 et au fil des
années jusqu'à 2018 les parents ont
investi pour faire de plus en plus un
rôle de plus en plus de prix pour
arriver et atteint en 2010 8 32 tous
les projets financés par le feader et et
l'investissement ce bâtiment d'élevage
avec une extension et rénovation des
bâtiments existants en rajoutant
aujourd'hui avec un quota de truies
supplémentaire des boosts rui de passer
de 38 de 2018 à 40,58 en 2021 avec un
montant total d'investissement des 500
6000 euros et avec un effet adel 2 397
1000 euros
[Musique]
classe est fédérée abêtissement qu'ils
ont fait cette exploitation nous avons
pu améliorer nos résultats techniques
d'élevage et aussi de moderniser
l'ensemble de notre bâtiment en tm
d'électronique et en termes de facilités
physiques au niveau du matériel
d'alimentation
ma vision pour les cinq ans à venir pour
notre exploitation et de continuer à
pénaliser notre exploitation pour
pouvoir faire et diversifiée dans le
domaine de l'élevage pour continuer à
produire des produits locaux de qualité
pour l'ensemble des consommateurs est
aussi ramène notre il gagna dépendance
alimentaire